Привет! Блог про Prompt, про то, какие существуют инструменты, как эти нейронки отличаются, мы закрыли.
Вся теория, вся база осталась позади. Теперь давай посмотрим, какие вообще есть инструменты,
как они выглядят, как ими пользоваться и так далее. Первый из них — это MidJourney. Его мы разберём сегодня.
Сегодня такой обзорно-демонстрационный урок. Это значит, что повторять каждое движение за мной не обязательно,
главное — забрать карту, где что лежит, какие инструменты и ключевые рычаги, как всем этим
пользоваться, как задавать стиль, как собирать свой собственный стиль, ну и в целом формат взаимодействия
с MidJourney. Он такой довольно специфический по отношению к остальным инструментам. Мы уже знаем,
что MidJourney — диффузионная модель, и из этого, из её архитектуры следует, что её сильная сторона — это
художественный вкус, иллюстративный визуал, фотореализм с каким-то настроением, особым тоном. Она хорошо
работает там, где нужен вкус, и слабеет там, где нужно точное следование сложным инструкциям,
или, например, мелкий текст в кадре. То есть работает по принципу: «Я художник, я так вижу». Ты не можешь
сказать: «Размести здесь текст, размести здесь знак». Даже если ты будешь говорить, что в правой части
изображения, я хочу, чтобы было это, даже это она может проигнорировать. Поэтому получаем очень крутой
визуал, красивый, классный, но контролировать её очень тяжело. Поэтому, как правило, отсюда мы этот визуал
забираем и идём уже в другие модели, чтобы его поправить, доработать, сформировать из него стиль и, в общем,
развить как угодно. Тем не менее, внутренний инструментарий достаточно широкий. Сегодня мы
посмотрим, как это всё работает. И вполне возможно, что и этого инструмента тебе хватит для твоих задач.
Что вообще в Меджорни где лежит? Меджорни исторически жил в Дискорде. Изначально там он существовал.
И взаимодействие было исключительно через чатик, через задания команд и так далее. То есть,
своего нормального интерфейса он не имел. Сейчас же основное приложение находится в браузере,
то есть, это веб-версия, веб-приложение. То есть, работать с ним стало значительно удобнее,
потому что у него, как минимум, появился интерфейс, с которым можно нормально взаимодействовать.
Дискорд всё ещё существует, там можно с ним взаимодействовать, но теперь смысла в этом особо нет.
На слайде все основные 8 блоков, которые там есть, ну а мы давай посмотрим их уже в лайве.
Итак, первая вкладка - это Explore. Это твоя лента, в которой ты можешь подсматривать стили,
изображения, даже видео здесь можно генерировать. Это как раз основной источник нашего вдохновения.
нашего вдохновения, я бы сказал. Здесь ты можешь выбирать фильтрацию, что именно ты хочешь увидеть:
стили, готовые изображения, видео. Также можно нажать Randomize, чтобы перемешать,
посмотреть какие-то другие стили, если предыдущие тебе не понравились.
Также у нас здесь есть сортировка, рандом, самые горячие, самые часто используемые,
лучшие сегодня и самые актуальные по количеству лайков. И те, на которые ты сам поставил лайк.
И выберем, например, еще изображение. Здесь очень много классных визуально изображений.
Тут они в целом все классно выглядят. И в целом довольно редко даже палится, что это нейронка.
Выглядит все очень круто. Идем дальше. Следующая вкладка - это Create, то есть уже создание.
Здесь мы генерируем изображение, видео и так далее. Ну, по поводу видео здесь скорее анимация того, что у тебя есть, а не...
Тут не полноценная генерация видео, а анимация того, что есть. Вот, например, я запустил Loop, и у нас зацикленное видео,
которое возвращается на исходный кадр. Это очень удобно, если ты хочешь куда-то на сайт это вставить.
Но мы чуть позже посмотрим, как все это работает, пока двигаемся дальше.
Что еще на вкладке Create для нас важно?
Смотри, во-первых, ты можешь закидывать свои изображения, использовать их в качестве стартового фрейма при генерации видео.
То есть внешние можно даже сюда закидывать, они будут работать. Это удобно.
Также Image Prompt, то есть использовать изображение в качестве промпта, если хочешь генерировать новые изображения в этом же стиле.
Вот, например, закинем сюда это. Тут у нас слева переключение между режимом видео и режимом изображения.
Также тут при нажатии на настройки у нас есть дополнительные настройки.
Сейчас по ним тоже давай кратко пробежимся.
Во-первых, Aspect Ratio, соотношение сторон. Здесь мы можем выбирать совершенно любое.
Ты можешь вводить свои числа. Здесь это удобно организовано.
Когда ты устанавливаешь здесь Aspect Ratio, то есть делаешь это нормально в интерфейсе, в конечном итоге, когда ты пишешь какой-то промпт, к нему добавляется еще AR 16 на 9.
Это как раз таки те команды, те теги, о которых ранее мы говорили, когда разбирали промптинг.
Здесь, благодаря тому, что у нас нормальное веб-приложение, он делает это автоматически.
Но не все команды реализованы через интерфейс, но тех, что тут есть, нам вполне достаточно, хватит с головой.
Итак, Landscape 16 на 9. Дальше.
Модель. Какую мы используем модель?
Здесь, смотри, мы можем переключаться между стандартным и HD режимом, и здесь же мы можем выбирать модель.
Каждая модель в Midjourney привносит что-то свое.
Какие-то фичи появляются в ней полностью.
Каких-то переносятся все фичи из предыдущей модели, в каких-то появляются новые.
Какие-то урезаются в плане функционала.
Здесь, например, самая последняя, самая актуальная модель 8.1 на момент записи.
Если мы поставим модель, например, седьмую, то здесь у нас еще появляется OmniReference.
Мы знаем, что OmniReference - это хорошо подходит, когда у нас какой-нибудь шот конкретного объекта, продукта, человека.
Можно использовать OmniReference.
Но имей в виду, что одна из десяти генераций действительно будет следовать хорошо этому OmniReference.
Здесь это все-таки креативная диффузионная модель, поэтому с такими и работать тяжеловато.
Так или иначе, возвращаем 8.1 самую последнюю модель.
RAW и Standard.
Старается сделать изображение как-то более чисто.
В стандартном режиме мы используем в основном, потому что хотим от Midjourney добиться именно крутого его фирменного визуала.
Поэтому, если ты как основной генератор изображения Midjourney используешь, да, тебе может RAW пригодиться.
Ну, а вообще, можем стандартный включать и забыть про эту функцию.
Далее, стилизация.
На этом ползунке то, как сильно Midjourney добавляет свою собственную стилизацию.
Если же опять нам нужно, чтобы все было максимально просто, реалистично, с фотореализмом, выбираем режим RAW, стилизацию вообще в ноль и едем дальше.
100 - это нормальное значение.
В целом, с ним можно хороший визуал получать.
Хотим больше - идем до, ну, примерно, 500 - 450.
Больше - уже она сильно креативит.
Тут что угодно может быть.
Дальше - awareness или странность.
То, насколько она будет креативна именно в плане композиции.
Насколько она далеко уйдет от, там, какого-то ожидаемого результата.
Это, опять же, тебе подходит, если ты хочешь получить какой-то интересный, необычный визуал.
Но, на самом деле, обычно вот конкретно этим параметром я не пользуюсь и так получается классно.
Но, если хочешь, чтобы модель тебя прямо удивила, добавила что-то совершенно несвойственное, казалось бы, твоему запросу,
то можешь выкручивать эту странность.
И последнее - это variate.
Здесь, если ты обратишь внимание, когда мы генерируем изображения, они сразу генерируются пачкой.
Вот мой промпт, он сделал четыре таких изображения.
Генерирует он всегда по четыре штуки.
И вот этот variate параметр определяет, а насколько разными будут эти вариации.
Эта штука хорошо помогает, когда мы только ищем визуал.
Соответственно, нам нужно много разных вариантов, а мы из них сможем в дальнейшем выбрать.
Дальше - more options, скорость, relax и fast.
Fast - это быстро, relax - медленно.
Но здесь есть одна ключевая особенность.
В режиме relax, то есть чуть помедленнее, на том тарифе, который я вам советую, можно генерировать сколько угодно.
То есть, покупаешь один раз подписку и в relax генерируешь хоть весь день.
О тарифах мы поговорим в самом конце, поэтому об этом пока не думай.
Далее у нас разрешение видео - SD HD и Video Batch Size.
То есть, по сколько видео он будет генерировать?
По четыре штуки, по две или по одному?
Ну, наверное, лучше по одному.
Я здесь пока поставлю единичку.
Итак, я закинул изображение, которое у меня получилось в прошлом уроке.
Стилизацию поставлю 100.
Style Reference у нас уже есть, хотелось бы, чтобы он его придерживался.
Дальше.
Вариативность.
Давай поставим 20.
Возможно, он как-то разовьет этот стиль, сделает его более прикольным.
Ну, и немного awareness поставим тут 8.
В принципе, нам этого достаточно.
Видео мы не будем генерировать.
Здесь у нас все стоит как надо.
И давай в этом же стиле сгенерируем, ну, что-нибудь вообще совсем другое.
Собака прыгает за тарелкой.
Я включу здесь сразу Fast режим, чтобы это было побыстрее.
И подождем.
Как видишь, генерирует он сразу по 4 изображения.
И здесь мы сразу видим, какие команды он добавлял к промпту.
KS20 здесь называется, это вариативность.
Он поставил тот параметр, который здесь мы выставляли.
То же самое Aspect Ratio.
Версия Mid Journey, в которой все генерируется.
Генерируется.
И странность 8.
Вот.
Изображения довольно разные получились, но мы видим, что не особо он последовал за стилем изображения.
Там у нас масляная краска.
Здесь он не стал этому следовать.
Ну, как бы так.
Немного похоже, но в целом совсем не то.
Теперь, какая у нас есть навигация тут?
Понравилось тебе какое-то из изображений, что ты можешь с ним сделать?
Первое, что тут появляется, это сделать вариации.
Very Subtle, Very Strong.
Very Subtle - это значит почти ничего особо не менять.
Давай это нажмем сразу.
И Very Strong - сильно поменять композицию.
Сейчас мы посмотрим на разницу.
В плане анимации, что у нас здесь происходит?
Я здесь выставил количество генерируемых видео на единичку.
Соответственно, он одно видео и генерирует.
Но на 35% уже готово.
То есть, вариации, которые больше будут совпадать с оригиналом.
И мы здесь видим, что композиционно в целом у нас все то же самое.
Меняется ковер на фоне, меняется немного объекты, но в целом то же самое изображение.
Просто в разных его вариациях.
Возможно, нам где-то тарелка не понравилась, не понравилась как она стоит.
Вот мы можем выбрать из еще дополнительных вариантов.
И при вариации Strong - сильный, у нас здесь все меняется сильнее.
Здесь она стоит на задних лапах, здесь она присела.
Сам стиль изображения меняется, положение тарелки, композиция.
Тут собака уже слева.
Это более мощные вариации.
Тут вот он сделал вообще как будто это мозаика.
Для генерации видео он берет промт, который был использован для генерации изображения.
И сам, в общем-то, по-своему здесь решил как-то видео собрать.
Вот, выглядит достаточно реалистично на самом деле.
Теперь, если мы откроем какое-нибудь из изображений, здесь у нас есть еще ряд параметров.
Также здесь предусмотрена вариация Subtle Strong опять, которую мы только что смотрели.
Есть у нас Rerun, то есть заново запустить генерацию с теми же самыми вводными.
Есть возможность перейти в Edit режим, изменить это изображение.
Это мы посмотрим чуть позже.
Есть Run as HD, то есть запустить генерацию с теми же самыми вводными, но в HD режиме.
Это будет быстрее, а качество будет чуть проще.
Также можно использовать из этого изображения отдельные куски для новых генераций.
Промт нам не нужен, ничего нам не надо.
Нам нужен только стиль из этого изображения.
Нажимаем Style и он автоматически это изображение добавляет в качестве Style Reference.
Все, тут уже пишем Prompt и двигаемся дальше.
То же самое можно использовать.
Изображение, Prompt, я думаю понятно.
И последнее это анимирование изображений.
По умолчанию, как видишь, он запускает автоматический режим Low Motion.
То есть, что-то там в кадре будет происходить, при этом движений будет достаточно мало.
Но мы видели, что у нас там собака как будто в замедленном действии.
Какие здесь вообще могут генерироваться видео?
Авто и Loop.
Авто - это что-то происходит и конечный кадр отличается от начального.
И Loop - это зацикленное видео.
То есть, конец и начало совпадают.
Для того, чтобы ты мог это вставить, оно бесконечно проигрывалось бесшовно.
Но не всегда это работает.
То есть, иногда где-то меняется цветокор к концу видео.
Видно этот стык.
Поэтому тут тоже придется несколько раз помучиться, прежде чем он сгенерирует то, что нужно.
И, как ты уже понял, по количеству движений, по сложности этого видео у нас делится на Low Motion и High Motion.
То есть, если мы хотим, чтобы это было зацикленное изображение, мы берем Loop.
Если хотим, чтобы оно на действие было насыщенным, то выбираем High Motion.
Давай сюда нажмем и посмотрим, что он сгенерирует.
Ну, видео достаточно странно получилось.
Собака, видимо, ловит тарелки и кладет их на место.
Вот.
Но, как видишь, видео зациклено и даже на самом деле сейчас по кадру, по цветокору все у нас совпадает.
То есть, да, можем его прямо сейчас на сайт закинуть и оно будет зацикленным.
В целом, эту штуку мы можем активно использовать.
Итак, в целом, по режиму создания мы прошли.
Здесь у нас еще есть такой параметр, как персонализация.
Мы чуть позже с этим разберемся.
А пока давай двигаться дальше.
Здесь у нас также есть вкладка Edit.
Это редактирование изображений.
Мы уже знаем, что есть InPaint, OutPaint и так далее.
Здесь все это расположено в одном месте.
Но, опять же, имея в виду, это креативная модель.
Если ты что-то конкретное хочешь дорисовать, то с этим могут быть проблемы.
Но, в целом, уже есть такая возможность и это очень круто.
Мы можем сразу перейти сюда в Edit и выбрать какое-то из наших изображений.
Можно из режима Create, например, нажать Edit и перейти сразу сюда.
Здесь по умолчанию это в таком сжатом режиме.
Это не совсем удобно.
Давай нажмем Open in Edit tab и вот уже в режиме на вкладке Edit поработаем с этим изображением.
Что мы здесь можем сделать?
Мы знаем, что при OutPaint, InPaint у нас есть такое понятие, как маска.
Вот здесь с помощью Paint мы этой маской и пользуемся.
Либо выбираем Smart Select и выбираем конкретную область.
Либо выбираем Paint и рисуем, где мы что хотим изменить.
Берем Erase и выделяем ту область, в которой хотим генерировать.
Я хочу, например, вместо этой тарелки что-нибудь другое.
Какая-то будет фарфоровая статуэтка.
Он нам сгенерировал 4 вариации.
Первый из них - это подсвечник.
Вторая - прям очень реалистичное изображение женщины, уже не статуэтка.
Третья - статуэтка, но собаки, причем с таким каким-то церковным платком на голове.
И последняя - еще одна маленькая статуэтка, уже что-то среднее между статуей и живым человеком.
Для каких-то конкретных правок, чтобы получить то, что ты хочешь, не очень Edit в Major не подходит.
Здесь она может быть слишком креативной.
При этом, если мы выберем седьмую модель, например, во-первых, она сделала это быстрее, во-вторых, здесь уже больше что-то похожее на правду.
Похоже на статуэтку, но непонятно какая-то маленькая голова, где что.
То есть, по очертаниям видно, что статуэтка, но что там конкретно - сомнительно.
Дальше просто шар и еще две каких-то странных маленьких фигуры.
И второй режим здесь - это Retexture, то есть, ретекстурировать.
Но, по большому счету, это то же самое, что вариация практически.
То есть, композиция вся сохраняется, но немного меняются все объекты.
Пока этой штукой не особо вижу смысла пользоваться.
Дальше у нас вкладка Organize.
Здесь вообще все, что мы генерировали, мы можем через фильтры посмотреть, что в каких моделях было сделано.
Может быть удобно, если у тебя прям большой пак работ.
Дальше у нас начинается целая подгруппа.
Называется Эстетика.
Первое - Персонализация.
Второе - Мудборды.
Третье - Style Creator.
Смысл всех трех вкладок в том, чтобы тебе создавать твои персонализированные стили.
Зайдем в первую вкладку - Персонализация.
Здесь я уже обмолвился, что есть у нас вот этот вот параметр персонализации.
Можно его включать и отключать.
Из чего это состоит, как это выглядит.
Здесь у тебя нет никакого профиля.
И тут ты можешь обучить модель пониманию того, что ты вообще считаешь красивым.
Давай покажу, как это происходит.
Нажимаем New Profile.
Ну, в моем случае, потому что у меня здесь уже есть профили готовые.
И переходим в него.
Теперь, что здесь происходит?
Он выдает тебе кучу всяких рандомных изображений.
Ты выбираешь те, которые тебе кажутся красивыми.
Мне нравится, например, это изображение.
Это выглядит странно и гишно.
Вот эта штука классная.
И таким образом просто протыкиваешь, пока здесь полоска у тебя не заполнится.
Если она заполнилась, значит он такой: "Все, я понял, что тебе нравится.
Можем уже с этим стилем генерировать".
В Mid Journey иногда появляется изображение с такой достаточно странной тематикой.
Вот, например, здесь все розовое.
Священник, скелет.
Ну, выглядит жутко.
Но это еще цветочки.
Когда я только начинал собирать свой профиль, мне понравилось пару изображений не по наполнению, а именно по стилистике.
По тому, какие там были цвета, как был выставлен кадр.
Но наполнение там было как раз таки вот с такой мрачной тематикой.
И когда я выбрал парочку из них и начал двигаться дальше, в дальнейшем моя лента превратилась в какую-то, я не знаю, ленту сатаниста.
Поэтому имей в виду, что то, что ты выбираешь в дальнейшем, он подобное и будет тебе предлагать.
Вот это, кстати, очень красиво.
И базово, когда ты только заходишь в меджорни, вот взял ты подписку, очень круто будет свою персонализацию составить.
Повыбирать, что тебе больше нравится, чтобы в дальнейшем, когда ты просто ищешь тот самый стиль.
Вот, кстати, один из примеров жутко какой-то фигни.
Чтобы в дальнейшем он сразу генерировал тебе то, что тебе, скорее всего, понравится.
Когда ты ему выкручиваешь стилизацию, выкручиваешь ему вариативность, странность, он, скорее всего, будет подстраиваться под тебя.
И сразу давать годные варианты, то, что тебе зайдет.
Но это как бы базовый формат использования, тот, чем ты будешь пользоваться в начале.
Но когда ты, например, собираешь айдентику, когда ты, например, ищешь айдентику, ищешь визуал какого-то своего проекта,
ты можешь создавать новый профиль, как это сделал я в самом начале, и выбирать то, что тебе кажется подойдет к нему.
Например, тебе нравится это изображение с котом, такое рисованное, мрачноватое, тоже абстрактное.
Все, выбираешь его, двигаешься дальше, со временем он будет давать все больше и больше изображений, которые под этот стиль подходят.
Таким образом, ты новый профиль этот создаешь.
После чего, при генерации изображения, ты включаешь персонализацию и здесь выбираешь этот самый профиль.
Вот у меня есть, например, глобальный профиль из того, что мне нравится, и дополнительный профиль, посвященный интерьерам.
Когда я что-то хочу генерировать для интерьерного дизайна.
Открываю этот профиль и он предлагает добить его, то есть еще что-то повыбирать.
Здесь, на самом деле, он выбирает какой-то полный рандом.
Возможно, это в силу того, что у нас обновилась модель.
Тут все посвящено интерьерам, поэтому я дальше выбираю именно какие-то интерьерные шоты, чтобы он понимал, как с ними работать.
И тут ты можешь заметить, что стиль у меня такой достаточно специфичный, с мягкими какими-то размытиями, фиолетовым цветом.
Давай попробуем что-нибудь сгенерировать.
Переходим в Create.
Используем только текстовый промпт, не используем никакие стили.
И включаем персонализацию.
Dog Jumping for the Plate.
Включаем ее, отключаем персонализацию и переиспользуем.
То же самое запускаем.
И посмотрим сейчас на разницу.
Без моей персонализации такие достаточно обычные изображения.
Выглядят нормально, но максимально базово.
Со включенным моим стилем мы видим, что здесь у нас другая уже цветокоррекция, другая обработка.
Есть такие абстрактные композиции.
Здесь вообще доберман с таким прям сочным освещением, брызгами красивое фото.
И здесь тоже такие притушенные немного цвета.
То есть разница значительная при включении персонализации.
Дальше у нас модборды.
Здесь по большому счету то же самое, но при этом ты можешь выбирать не из рандомных изображений, которые он там на ходу генерирует или подтягивает, а закидывать свои собственные.
Загружать изображения, использовать из тех, которые у тебя уже были при генерации.
У каждого модборда, каждого стиля, каждой персонализации есть свой код.
Если мы, например, здесь нажмем using prompt, то увидим этот код.
P, M745 и так далее.
И в дальнейшем, когда ты генерируешь какое-то изображение, точно так же при персонализации ты можешь выбрать, например, модбор 2.
Все, он в этом стиле будет для тебя генерировать.
Дальше у нас style creator, создание своего стиля.
Тут уже штука такая комбинированная, например, я хочу сделать стиль коммерческой рекламы продуктов питания.
На английский это переведу.
Сюда можешь также закинуть изображение, выставить настройки и включить персонализацию с уже готовым каким-то твоим модбордом, еще чем-то, чтобы от этого отталкиваться.
После чего я здесь персонализацию выключу, запущу старт, он нам генерирует кучу вариаций.
Какая-то мрачная тематика, опять черепа у него, ретро эстетика.
Все, можем здесь двигаться дальше и добавлять стили, которые тебе больше подходят.
Здесь удобнее, что на одной и той же композиции ты можешь смотреть, как это ляжет, как это может выглядеть и таким образом свой стиль собрать.
Вот я насобирал уже достаточно много изображений.
В целом, чем дальше мы идем, тем больше мне нравится, что он показывает.
Если в начале у нас много было изображений в стиле нарисованном, то теперь у нас почти все реализм.
Он понял, что меня интересуют только реальные снимки и дает очень много классных кадров на самом деле.
Все, здесь мы прошли порог, который называется "Идеал минимум".
Соответственно, стиль наш уже можно считать сформированным.
Ну, выберем еще тут парочку изображений.
Нажимаем "End session", "Окончить сессию".
Наш стиль создался.
И обрати внимание, что готовность стиля говорит о том, что все, теперь он в этом же виде будет тебе давать визуалы, готовые стили, которые ложатся в то, что ты ищешь.
И когда ты выбираешь из них, он автоматически генерирует по этому промпту в этом стиле, уже готовом, существующем, изображение для тебя.
Вот, например, реклама еды, вот у нас девушка, какие-то, я не знаю, крабы, лобстеры, бургеры и так далее.
Все это плюс-минус в одной и той же стилистике и собирает он это автоматически.
Таким образом, когда ты уже нагенеришь какое-то количество подходящих по стилю изображений, ты можешь собрать уже свой мудборд, новый мудборд из готовых твоих изображений.
Вот последние четыре точно ложатся в мою стилистику, я бы даже сказал побольше.
Нажимаем Don, все, мудборд нашей вот коммерческой съемки еды, назовем его Food и теперь в персонализации выберем Moodboard Food и введем там, я не знаю, какая-нибудь Coca-Cola.
Все, в соответствии с этим мудбордом он нам сделал четыре вариации какого-то также коммерческого снимка для Coca-Cola.
Все, в той же стилистике выглядит круто.
Также ты можешь здесь использовать опять же Coca-Cola, персонализация и еще сюда закинуть стиль и сгенерируется еще круче.
Но просто стиль у тебя не всегда хранится, не всегда ты его помнишь, а мудборд у тебя точно останется.
Собрал еще четыре классных снимка, выглядит очень атмосферно, красиво.
Теперь смотри, еще одна ключевая особенность вот связанная с этим выбором стиля.
Помимо того, что ты собираешь свои стили, собираешь свои мудборды, выбираешь из готовых и так далее, ты можешь просто переиспользовать стили людей.
Они точно так же их могут очень долго собирать и почему бы этим не воспользоваться.
Выходим в Explore и здесь просто ищем то, что тебе нравится.
Здесь всегда есть из чего почерпнуть вдохновение.
Кстати, опять зловещее очень изображение.
Вот, например, это вообще максимально модно выглядит.
Это собрано не на стиле, это собрано с помощью профиля человека.
Просто берем его профиль, он копируется в prompt и можем его переиспользовать, генерировать какое-то свое изображение.
При этом еще добавив персонализацию.
Но мы сейчас отключим это, чтобы у нас точно получилось.
Поставим, например, девушка на скейте.
И еще по поводу промптов на русском и английском языке.
Лучше он воспринимает промпты на английском языке.
Да, на русском он тоже их понимает, но может очень странно искажать изображение.
Например, если я писал инженер на английском, то он визуализировал просто какого-то дефолтного нормального мужика.
Красивого нормального парня.
Если я писал инженер на русском, то он сразу мог нарисовать какой-то очень старый олдовый свитер из 90-х, раннее облысение, скуфа.
Ну, вот почему-то он на русском языке инженера воспринимает именно так.
Соответственно, имея в виду, что он может региональный колорит добавлять в зависимости от того, на каком языке ты пишешь.
Тут, например, это не так заметно, но если мы откроем это изображение, то увидим, что тут он что-то на кириллице пытался написать.
Как раз потому, что мы делали на русском.
Кстати, изображения достаточно классные получились, вот это вообще фаворит.
Вот такое изображение ты не получишь в какой-нибудь там Nano Banana, в чате GPT и так далее.
Ты можешь очень долго описывать, что там, какое должно быть освещение, какая палитра, камера и так далее.
Но вот просто по одному короткому промпту девушка на скейте, он не даст такого классного, сочного визуала, который уже хоть сейчас, дальше ты можешь переиспользовать.
И в этом, конечно, основная сила Mid Journey.
Можем еще здесь сделать несколько вариаций.
Тут, например, штаны эти отрестовал как какую-то упаковочную пленку, мне это не очень нравится.
Здесь уже прикольные голубые джинсы.
Если хотим как-то композицию иначе собрать, вот здесь у нас уже вообще другие наряды.
Девушка даже немного другая.
Например, вот это изображение тоже выглядит круто, сочно.
Здесь у нее, правда, уже какая-то броня появилась.
Еще в low-motion loop это добавить и создать вообще видео.
Также сюда добавили еще режим чата.
Тут ты можешь как бы общаться с моделью, поправь то это, но пока это очень слабо работает.
Mid Journey все-таки не для этого, поэтому это можно оставить.
И последнее - task, то есть задачи.
Ты можешь здесь выполнять разные задачи и получать там дополнительно токены, часы и прочее.
Мне пока ни разу не пригодилось.
Здесь в целом лимиты очень щедрые.
Итак, мы разобрали все, что здесь есть.
Давай еще раз вкратце по стилистикам.
У нас есть Style Ref, у нас есть персонализация.
Мы посмотрели, как ее собирать.
И у нас есть Orif, то есть Object Reference.
Но он доступен не на всех моделях.
На самой последней его нет, на предыдущих.
Может добавлять дополнительно еще своих персонажей.
Не слишком он им следует, еще раз повторюсь.
Но возможность такая есть.
Дальше, по параметрам отдельно.
Мы уже в целом все посмотрели.
Aspect Ratio, стилизация, хаос или вариативность.
Странность, Row и Negative Prompt.
Это еще одна полезная штука.
Когда ты не хочешь, чтобы он что-то добавлял в кадр, пишешь No и описываешь, чего не должно быть.
Например, No Dogs, No Cats и так далее.
Если ты хочешь серию из изображений не четырех, а шести или восьми сразу, можешь это явно дописывать.
SV и число, сколько тебе надо изображений.
И Style Weight, то есть вот эта стилизация.
По умолчанию стоит 100, 200, 500.
В целом еще норм.
Потом уже вообще могут быть какие-то непредсказуемые результаты.
И теперь самое главное - тарифы.
Смотрите, после этого урока мы еще посмотрим такой инструмент, как Крия.
Там тоже есть и аналог мудборда, и собирание своих стилей, своих моделей и некая креативность.
Поэтому, в целом, если ты не собираешься постоянно этим заниматься, тебе будет достаточно Крии.
В целом, на весь этот модуль Крии будет достаточно, просто чтобы посмотреть, как это работает.
Но MidJourney в своей креативности, в своей стильности инструмент незаменимый.
Поэтому, если ты этим постоянно занимаешься, то его нужно обязательно брать.
Дальше.
У нас четыре основных тарифа.
Basic, Standard, Pro и Mega.
Basic - 10$, Standard - 30$, Pro - 60$, Mega - 120$.
Я советую тебе брать режим Standard.
Это самый оптимальный режим.
И смотри почему.
Во-первых, тут у нас расходуются не токены в MidJourney,
а часы, которые тратятся на генерацию.
Вот у тебя 5, 10, 20 минут тратится.
И когда этот лимит истекает, то, соответственно, его надо докупать, обновлять и так далее.
Смотри.
В чем прикол именно стандартного тарифа?
В Basic за 10$ у тебя 3,3 часа.
Вот сгенерировал ты там какое-то количество картинок - все, гуляй.
А в стандартном режиме за 30$ в месяц у тебя, во-первых, 15 часов именно быстрой генерации.
Это примерно там больше тысячи изображений, что дофига.
И если даже ты их умудрился потратить, у тебя есть безлимитная релакс-очередь.
Мы знаем, что тут при генерации мы можем выбирать режим релакс.
И в этом режиме, на этом тарифе, ты можешь генерировать хоть до посинения вообще сколько угодно.
Каждый день по 500 изображений в режиме релакс ты можешь делать.
Разница только, соответственно, в скорости генерации изображений.
Поэтому классная штука, советую использовать ее.
Но в стандартном режиме твои генерации могут стать публичными.
Точно так же кто-то, листая ленту, может твою стилистику найти, ее переиспользовать,
использовать готовое изображение.
Если вдруг для тебя это не подходит, если тебе это не нравится, то тебе нужен уже про тариф.
Там ты можешь делать уже приватные генерации, которые никто не увидит.
Но в целом смысла в этом особо не вижу.
Стандартный тариф за 30 долларов самый оптимальный вариант для самого широкого использования.
Если хочешь просто попробовать, просто посмотреть, можешь попробовать тариф Basic.
Он всего 10 долларов в месяц стоит.
На этом все.
Домашнего задания с проверкой не будет.
Все, что тебе нужно сделать, зайти в Меджорни и собрать свой стиль, свою персонализацию.
Выбрать изображение, которое тебе нравится.
Ну и попробовать что-то погенерить.
Создавать ничего не нужно.
Твоя задача в рамках домашней работы просто ознакомиться с этим инструментом.
На этом все.
Увидимся в следующем уроке.